the College Admission scandal continues
to be a huge story you know what I'm
talking about
thank you it's a sullen fifth grade
class what's your point it's a big deal
yeah cheating to get their kids at
colleges this is a massive scandal
lawmakers in Washington are taking a
closer look at the way parents donate to
universities and one of the that not
gonna change anything
okay I'm sorry what what did you say I
just they're just gonna find another way
to gain the system the rich do it all
the time and everybody cheats one way or
the other right
okay well wait a minute okay that it's
hardly anyone agree with you but uh but
but really what you're saying that
doesn't make it right yeah well right or
wrong it's reality get a day at work
they wanted me to take a drug test I
wouldn't have passed so I bought some
clean urine off a Craigslist and boom
still day manager forever21
okay well that's not good I mean you
admit that was illegal yeah why I'm not
running for Pope check this out
I told my doctor I had shooting leg
pains and now boom guaranteed parking
spot wait that's right
so you're not you're not really disabled
actually I am in fact I'm so nearsighted
I'm legally not allowed to drive so I
paid a guy to go to the DMV to take my
eye exam for me and now boom license to
drive
you realize you just publicly confessed
to several counts of criminal fraud yeah
well I'm not an idiot I'm not gonna say
this stuff when you start the show we
we've started the show we're taping the
show right now oh my god you idiot you
screwed up big time who takes me from my
seat and all because you did not know
the starting time of Conan's show so
many witnesses
[Music]
guys guys just go oh sorry
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [Applause]
[Music]